how many intelligent alien civilizations
do you think are out there yeah boy I
have you know no expertise in that
whatsoever yeah you haven't met any I I
I have met the ones we've made I think
that I mean exactly in some sense with
synthetic biology are you not creating
aliens I absolutely think so because
because look all of life all of St all
standard model systems are an N of one
course of evolution on earth right and
trying to make conclusions about biology
from looking at life on Earth is like
testing your theory on the same data
that generated it it's all it's all kind
of like locked in so we absolutely have
to create novel uh examples that have no
history on Earth that don't you know as
xenobots have no history of selection to
be a good xenobot the cells have
selection for various things but but the
xenobot itself never existed before and
so we can make chimeras you know we make
um frogs that are you know sort of half
frog have Axolotl you can make all sorts
of high broads right constructions of
living to issue with robots and whatever
we need to be making these things until
we find actual aliens because otherwise
we're just looking at an N of one set of
examples all kinds of Frozen accidents
of evolution and so on we need to go
beyond that to really understand biology
but we're still even if you when you do
a synthetic biology you're locked in to
the basic components
of
um the way biology is done on this Earth
yeah right yeah yeah
and also the basic constraints to the
environment even artificial environments
are construct in the lab are tied up to
the environment I mean what do you okay
let's say there is I mean what I think
is there's
a nearly infinite number of intelligent
civilizations living or dead out there
um
if you pick one out of the box
what do you think it would look like
so
in in when you think about synthetic
biology
or creating synthetic organisms
how hard is it to create something
that's very different
yeah I think it's very hard to create
something that's very different right
it's um uh we are just locked in both
both uh experimentally and in terms of
our imagination right it's very hard and
you also emphasize several times that
the idea of shape yeah the individual
cell get together with other cells and
they kind of they're going to build a
shape so it's shape and function but
shape is a critical thing yeah so here
I'll take a stab I mean I I agree with
you to whatever extent though that we
can say anything I I do think that
there's you know probably an infinite
number of of different uh different
um uh architectures with with our with
interesting cognitive properties out
there uh what can we say about them I
think that
um the only things that are going I I
don't think we can rely on any of the
typical stuff you know carbon based yeah
no no like I think all of that is just
um you know us being having having uh a
lack of imagination but I think the
things that um are going to be Universal
if anything is are things for example
driven by resource limitation the fact
that you are fighting a hostile world
and you have to draw a boundary between
yourself and the world somewhere the
fact that that boundary is not given to
you by anybody you have to you have to
assume it you know uh estimate it
yourself in the fact that you have to
coarse grain your experience in the fact
that you're going to try to minimize
surprise and the fact that like these
these are the things that I think are
fundamental about biology none of the
you know the facts about the genetic
code or even the fact that we have genes
or or the biochemistry of it I don't
think any of those things are
fundamental but um it's going to be a
lot more about the information and about
the creation of the self the fact that
so in my in my framework selves are
demarcated by uh the scale of the goals
that they can pursue so from little tiny
local goals to like massive you know
planetary scale goals for for certain
humans
um and everything and everything in
between so you can draw this like
cognitive light cone about that that
determines the the scale of the goals
you could possibly pursue I think those
kinds of Frameworks uh like that like
active inference and so on are going to
be universally applicable but but none
of the other things that are that are
typically um discussed
quick pause during the bathroom break
we were just talking about uh you know
aliens and all that that's a funny thing
which is yeah I don't know if you've
seen them there's a kind of debate that
goes on about cognition and plants and
what can you say about different kinds
of computation and cognition and plans
and I always I always look at that so
I'm like if if you're weirded out by
cognition in Plants you're not ready for
exobiology right if if you know
something that's that similar here on
Earth is already like freaking you out
then I think there's going to be all
kinds of cognitive life out there that
we're gonna have a really hard time
recognizing
I think robots will help us yeah
like expand our mind about cognition
either that or the word like xenobots so
and they maybe becomes the same thing is
you know really when the human Engineers
the thing at least in part and then is
able to achieve some kind of cognition
that's different than what you're used
to then you start to understand like oh
cut you know every living organism is
capable of cognition oh I need to kind
of broaden my understanding what
cognition is but do you think plants um
like when you when you eat them are they
screaming I don't know about screaming I
think you have to see what I think when
I eat a salad yeah good yeah I think you
have to scale down the expectations in
terms of right so so probably they're
not screaming in the way that we would
be screaming however there's plenty of
data on Plants being able to um to do
anticipation and certain kinds of memory
and and so on
um I think you know what you just said
about robots uh I I hope you're right
and I hope that's but but there's two
there's two ways that people can take
that right so one way is exactly what
you just said to try to kind of expand
their expand their their their Notions
for that category the other way people
often go is uh they just sort of Define
the term as if if it's not a natural
product it's it's just faking right it's
not really intelligence if it was made
by somebody else because it's that same
it's the same thing they can see how
it's done and once you see how it's like
a magic trick when you see how it's done
it's not as fun anymore and and I think
people have a real tendency for that and
they sort of which which I find really
strange in the sense that if somebody
said to me
we have this this sort of blind like
like uh hill climbing search and then
and then we have a really smart team of
Engineers which one do you think is
going to produce a system that has good
intelligence I think it's really weird
to say that it only comes from the blind
search right it can't be done by people
who by the way can also use evolutionary
techniques if they want to but also
rational design I think it's really
weird to say that
um real intelligence only comes from
Natural Evolution
so I hope you're right I hope people
take it in the other the other way well
there's a nice shortcut so I work with
Lego robots a lot now for my for my own
uh
personal pleasure
uh not in that way internet uh so uh the
four legs
and uh one of the things that
changes my experience with the robots a
lot is um
when I can't understand why I did a
certain thing and there's a lot of ways
to engineer that
meet the person that created the
software that runs it
there's a lot of ways for me to build
that software in such a way that I don't
exactly know why it did a certain basic
decision
of course as an engineer you can go in
and start to look at logs you can log
all kind of data sensory data the the
decisions you made the you know all the
outputs in your networks and so on but I
also try to really experience that
surprise and that really experience as
another person would that totally
doesn't know how it's built and I think
the magic is there and not knowing how
it works
that I think biology does that for you
through the layers of abstraction yeah
it because nobody really knows what's
going on inside the biological like each
one component is clueless about the big
picture I think there's actually really
cheap systems that can that can
illustrate that kind of thing which is
even like um you know uh fractals right
like you have a very small short formula
in Z and you see it and there's no magic
you're just going to crank through you
know Z squared plus C whatever you're
just going to crank through it but the
result of it is this incredibly Rich
beautiful image right that that just
like wow all of that was in this like 10
character long string like amazing so
the fact that you can you can know
everything there is to know about the
details and the process and all the
parts and everything like there's
literally no magic of any kind there and
yet the outcome is something that you
would never have expected and it's just
it just you know is incredibly rich and
and complex and beautiful